Speaker 1: So earlier in the program, we covered
the FBI raid on Rudy Giuliani's house, apartment
and office.
And we are still waiting to learn more about
what exactly is going on, what crimes is Rudy
suspected of and more information about that.
I have to play some of these clips for you
of Rudy Giuliani's son, Andrew Giuliani, as
well as just a random neighbor of Rudy's who
seems to be straight out of central casting,
making statements to the media yesterday outside
Rudy's home or office.
We'll start with Rudy, son.
This is Andrew Giuliani saying that what is
going on here should make it.
It's all political and everybody should be
furious.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Mind you, I'm speaking as a son
and a concerned American.
Anybody, any American, whether you were red
or blue, should be extremely disturbed by
what happened here today, despite the continued
politicization of the Justice Department.
This is disgusting.
This is absolutely absurd.
And it's the continued polarization of the
Justice Department that we have seen.
Speaker 1: So not exactly doing like a great
job there.
And then this is just so funny.
Andrew Giuliani says there is important evidence
in my father's home and office.
It's a Hunter Biden's laptop, but the feds
did not actually take that.
The real evidence of crimes, Andrew says,
I mean, it's the apple does not fall.
Far from the tree is Biden's laptop, which
they didn't take.
Speaker 3: The only piece of evidence that
they did not take up there today was the only
piece of incriminating evidence that is in
there.
And it does not belong to my father.
It belongs to the current president's son.
Speaker 1: They have figured out a way to
make this about Hunter Biden's laptop somehow.
And I don't know that Andrew Giuliani is really
doing his dad any any favors there.
Now, here's another funny thing.
Just for flavor and and context.
One of Rudy's neighbors in the building, she
appears to be straight out of central casting.
She gave a statement.
It's not clear whether she was just walking
back from getting groceries and stepped up
to the mic or if she was asked to come down.
I mean, this is just absolutely perfect.
She expresses being amused when her ex-husband
called her and said, hey, there's a raid going
on there.
Look out your window.
Speaker 4: The funniest thing is my ex-husband
called me and said, have you seen what's going
on?
And I said said, no, look out your window.
Speaker 1: So here is more from Rudy's neighbor,
Michelle, herbut I love this woman.
I know.
Speaker 4: I just saw people I probably saw
FBI jacket, but I just saw people, you know,
and I saw all of you and and I said.
What is going on,
Speaker 1: every detail is just written for
a movie and then on Fox News's The Five, Jesse
Watters, I guess in a serious manner, suggests
they really should have raided Hunter Biden's
house, not Rudy Giuliani's.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: That's when President Trump was
impeached the first time.
It was on the basis of putting pressure on
the Ukrainian president to get negative information
on Biden.
And I think we're just running in a circle
here, a back to that incident.
What do you make of this?
I think I speak for everybody on the show
when I say this, Rudy Giuliani is a national
treasure.
I don't disagree.
I speak for everyone on the show when I say
this.
The guy took on the mob and took on crime.
Al-Qaeda counselor to the president.
And now Democratic prosecutors want to lock
up a 76 year old icon for a lobbying technicality,
one because he advised the president that
he should fire a rotten ambassador.
You have to register to lobby for that.
Unabiding advises dad to fire a prosecutor.
Did he register?
Where is the raid on Hunter's house?
Speaker 1: I guess that's not comedy.
It's actually now, FOX News has made it complicated
for us because now that they have this comedy
show, Gutfeld, but it's not funny.
It's really hard to tell when you watch something.
Is this supposed to be a comedy show or not?
But Jesse Watters, I don't think that's a
joke, saying really the rage should be of
Hunter Biden's house.
So I don't know if that's comedy or a serious
segment, but just everyday, if you wrote this
into a screenplay, Hollywood producers would
say it's too over the top, just nobody.
It's implausible.
We need to make this less wacky.
But unfortunately or maybe fortunately, it's
the real story.
So we'll continue to follow the situation
with